Wenn Sie auf Ihre Hand drücken, das ist der Auriobon, der Druckschmerz,
wenn Sie das Spruch, das Außenwege oder das Innenwege drücken,
wenn Sie nach innen drücken oder außen drücken oder vorne, wo die Knie ist,
haben Sie Druckschmerzen gewissen.
Ist das eine gute Lösung?
Ist es eine gute Schale?
Haben Sie äusserliche Verletzung?
Wie sieht es aus?
Unfall der Verletzung, die Tätamusodischen ist das.
Unfall ist nicht der Fall.
Wenn Sie sich die Verletzung überwärmen,
dann ist das nicht der Fall.
Das ist schon ein sehr guter Punkt.
Dann ist es eine gute Frage.
Hier kann man dann auch überprüfen.
Warum ist es eine gute Frage?
Ich werde sie stationär aufnehmen. Es ist eine Routinefrage, damit wir sie nicht nur als Handgelenk sehen, sondern auch körperlich kennenlernen, falls irgendein Notfall eintritt, dass wir auch reagieren können.
Falls am Ende der Untersuchung alles gut ist und sie haben nur eine Stauffung und sie müssen vielleicht nicht im Krankenhaus bleiben, dann kann man ja das vernichten.
Aber damit ich die Arbeit schon mache und vorbereite, möchte ich gerne eine Allgemeine Anamnese, Gesamtbild sehen, damit ich weiß, welche Medikamente sie nehmen, ob sie Allergien haben und so.
Deswegen möchte ich sie speziell fragen. Da habe ich eine Frage-Muster und das möchte ich gerne mit ihnen durchgehen.
Wenn ich sie nicht mehr überführen möchte, dann werde ich mich nicht mehr überführen.
Ich werde mich nicht überführen, aber ich werde mich überführen.
Ich werde mich überführen, wenn ich sie überführen möchte.
Sie haben heute einen Verkehrsunfall gehabt. Wir möchten sie auf jeden Fall, auch wenn sie keine Verletzung haben, sie stationär einen Tag mindestens beobachten, 24 Stunden.
Deswegen möchte ich sie stationär aufnehmen und es ist mein Aufnahmebogen, den ich mit ihnen ausschüllen möchte, damit wir sie als gesamte Mensch dokumentieren.
Zum Beispiel.